the change that was made by the NFL back
in March to the pass interference rule
allowing replay review for all pass
interference calls and non calls
offensive and defensive spark by the NFC
Championship game and at some point the
competition can be realized we may have
gone too far with this we may have put
in place a blanket rule that is going to
require automatic replay review of a
bunch of plays so let's come up with a
different path here let's get licensed
from ownership to tweak the rule and
then let's convince the coaches that in
those final two minutes of either the
first half of the game we won't rely on
automatic review we rely on you to throw
the read challenge flag and you know
what that didn't go over very well with
the coaches and the end result at least
for now
according to NFL media ie according to
the NFL there's not going to be any
tweak to the rule that was put in place
so it's going to be automatic review for
everything related to pass interference
calls non calls offensive defensive and
that really can if they're not careful
Chris bogged down games bogged down
games this is the wrong decision for my
money okay I mean I just think this is
the wrong approach all together first of
all it looks like the coaches are trying
to you know skirt you know
responsibilities or being the guys that
are on the hook here let me finish here
for a second alright first I'll give
them one more red flag but don't put the
burden on the league right now
I mean why shouldn't the coaches are
being paid millions of dollars manage
the game the right way okay don't put
the burden on the league we're gonna be
right back in the same conversation next
year in the NFC Championship game if
they put the burden on the league we're
gonna go oh gosh you looked like there
was past interference across the field
and the replay guy and the booth didn't
call down in time and all of a sudden a
replay shows on you know one of the
networks and we go back so to me though
you're opening up a can of words you're
holding the league liable in the
gambling era like you have talked about
where everyone's gonna think the fix is
in according to what's reviewed what's
not reviewed oh that guys are confident
not if you're competent you got to be
competent and what will they
they're necessarily confident the last
few years they're what they've done is
they've put a mechanism in place now to
fix an egregious problem I believe they
said that's gone with sky judge I think
that sky judge is what they're gonna do
a year from now they're gonna do this
pass interference replay review for a
season and is going to Mar and undermine
the league's 100th season because it's
going to be an issue if they don't do it
right see here's the problem I don't
want to get too deep into the weeds with
this here's the fundamental problem the
league will not tell you because they
expose how far they went with this
without considering the unintended
consequences the standard for
overturning the ruling on the field
clear and obvious evidence that the
ruling on the field was incorrect the
standard for initiating an automatic
review is that there will be an
automatic review unless there's clear
and obvious evidence that the ruling on
the field was correct so you've got a
broad base a broad range right if
situations in pass interference where
there's going to be enough to say well
it's not clear and obvious the ruling
was correct we better have a full-blown
replay review so almost any pass unless
the guy is wide open right any pass
where you've got jostling where you've
got positioning where you've got pushing
any type of contact you're going to be
down that path where you need to have an
automatic full blown replay review and
they're not going to overturn it but
it's gonna take two minutes and it's
gonna slow the game down that's what
they're trying to avoid and you don't
want to admit it
because if they admit it then people
like us are gonna say why the hell
didn't you realize that when you put the
rule in place in the first place yeah
well I mean agreed Mike I'm with you
there and I think that's even more of a
reason to not have the rule set up this
way for now you know that I think
there's better ways to do it give the
coaches an extra challenge flag whatever
it may be but I don't want to be bogged
down with replay after replay after
replay and I think like you're saying
there's so many plays where there's
contact like that where we can go back
and go oh I don't know if that was pass
interference and it's still gonna come
down to human judgment and I think we're
gonna still be in this same place and a
lot of times where we're gonna go that
looks like pass interference to me and
you're gonna talk to me and go it didn't
look good bad to me and then we're gonna
argue about what the league called and I
just think it's opening up a can of
worms they're a little bit last point
for now you mentioned human judgment
human nature is influencing where
we are with this because the human
nature of a guy like rich McKay the
NFL's Competition Committee Chairman is
preventing him from saying you know what
we screwed this up we went too far we
went too far in March and we need to fix
this because of the very thing you and I
have been discussing an overabundance of
automatic replay reviews that will
happen under the current standard but
the coaches push back and now the
competition committee is boxed into a
corner and there's nothing they can do
other than let this season play out and
hope for the best
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports